this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
apple finally redesigned the ipad mini
we have the ipad mini 6 right here but
now the question is should you buy it or
should you spend 100 more and buy the
ipad air 4. well today we are going to
compare every single difference they
both have their strengths and their
weaknesses and by the end of the video
you will know which one you should buy
we'll be comparing the exterior
differences the speakers the displays
the cpu and the graphics performance
accessories and more starting out with
the exterior differences you guys could
see that there is a huge difference in
size based on the website and spec
sheets it doesn't sound like that big of
a difference but the ipad mini 6 is much
smaller than the ipad air 4. that could
be a good thing or a bad thing now
looking at the box we have a couple
differences
we are missing the little flash on the
ipad er4 even though it's more expensive
it does not come with the flash and with
that also the smart connector at the
bottom and we'll go into both of those
in just a little bit as far as weight i
definitely could tell the difference the
ipad mini 6 it just feels really
lightweight i feel i can hold it all day
whereas the 10.9 inch ipad air it's
definitely much heavier and that can be
tiring if you're gonna hold it for a
long time interestingly the ipad mini is
actually slightly thicker than the air
4. now the air fort also has the buttons
the volume buttons here at the same spot
they've always been whereas with the
mini apple has moved them right there to
the top on the left hand side because
they made room for the apple pencil
connector right here on the right side
because the mini is so small the apple
pencil literally takes almost the full
length of the ipad compared to the air 4
where obviously this thing's much larger
and you still have room for the volume
rocker now thankfully the ipad mini now
also gets usb type-c connectivity which
means that you have a lot more
flexibility than lightning you can use a
usb type-c to an hdmi cable instead of
having to buy the adapter from apple
which is great it's just a lot better
overall both of these are using apple's
new touch id sensor that is built into
the power button which is really handy
because you could just press the power
button and it'll log you in
automatically and read your fingerprint
it is a little bit easier to use on the
mini because of how small it is you can
reach up and access it either way
whereas with the air force larger so
you're shuffling your hands around more
so now right there as well you guys can
see we have two speaker girls and the
same thing goes for the mini finally the
mini has speakers on both sides at the
top there and then also at the bottom so
that if you're watching a movie a video
or a game you hear sound from both sides
which is great so before we jump into
the screen comparison let's go ahead and
compare the speakers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below and i
will say that these speakers these terms
of quality sound very similar now the
ipad air 4 is louder especially in the
high end frequencies those highs like
the vocals they stand out more whereas
the mini they seemed a little bit more
toned down
and the base between them surprisingly
is about the same so the same amount of
bass the volume it's just the highs that
stand out more so on the ipad air four
but let me know what you guys think down
below and now let's compare the displays
other than the size difference of 10.9
inches compared to 8.3 which by the way
doesn't sound like a lot but you guys
can see the screen difference is really
big everything else is very similar the
contrast is very similar both have the
same 500 nits of brightness so i
adjusted that top camera and as you guys
could see um they are very similar in
brightness viewing angles are also very
similar the one difference i see is that
the mini six it actually has a warmer
white balance when you have true tone
enabled which i do so it's just apple's
tuning both of them do support hdr
videos but for some reason when you're
watching these hdr videos the ipad mini
6 is actually brighter and hdr pops more
so now another difference you may notice
is that the black bars are bigger on the
ipad air 4 at the top and the bottom
than the ipad mini now that's because
ipad mini is actually more wide screen
than the air 4 is the aspect ratio is a
little bit different with that said if i
was buying an ipad to watch a lot of
movies or videos i would go for the ipad
air 4 just because you have that larger
display as i mentioned earlier both of
these now support the apple pencil 2
which you can tap on and it charges and
attaches magnetically which is nice with
that both of these have a 60 hertz
display so that means there is no 120
hertz promotion so there's no difference
as far as smoothness when you're
flipping through these home pages or
anything like that now the one
difference that we do have is that smart
connector that i showed off at the start
meaning that you can buy apple's magic
keyboard and you can attach it and then
you will have access to this nice
keyboard so you can type you can use the
trackpad and use it more like a laptop
replacement whereas the ipad mini 6 does
not have that so it will not be a laptop
replacement the screen is not really big
enough for that but because of this new
redesign they do have a new smart folio
which also uses magnets just like the
other tablets with this design to attach
and then not only does it protect the
front and then you can also
roll this up if you want to have like a
little stand for your ipad but it
protects the back as well which is very
convenient before we move on let me give
a shout out to the sponsor this video
squarespace if you've been thinking
about making your own website
squarespace is seriously the best way to
go you could build a great looking
website like we did with literally no
web making experience it doesn't matter
if you want a portfolio a blog
e-commerce or anything else you just
choose from one of their great templates
and customize blocks of text and images
it's incredibly simple it is affordable
and r has been running flawlessly for
years now bringing in tons of traffic
thanks to its built-in seo tools start
your free two-week trial with no credit
card required by going to
squarespace.com maxtec or by using the
custom link down below and when you're
ready to launch you will save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain and now let's get into the
performance and i'm extremely interested
in this because even though the ipad air
4 costs more money 100 more it comes
with the a14 bionic compared to the a15
in the ipad mini 6. now as far as ram we
used to have a difference the ipad mini
used to come with three gigs instead of
four now both of them come with four
gigs of ram which is great and as far as
graphics well
this thing has that five core graphics
processor but let's go ahead and start
out with the cpu and let's run a
geekbench 5. all right we have our
results and this is a lot closer than
you might expect as far as single core
we're going from 1579 to 1600 basically
the same and multi-core from 4215 to 45
19. not that much faster with the ipad
mini and that is for a couple of reasons
well first off the a14 in the ipad air
it's actually faster it runs quite a bit
quicker than the one in the iphone 12s
it's not limited by heat or thermals
it's not slowed down whereas the 815 and
the ipad mini it is actually slowed down
compared to the iphone 13s because they
want to save battery life so that is why
the scores are so close so as far as cb
performance there's really not that big
of a difference but now let's go ahead
and go back and we are gonna run the
compute test which looks at graphics all
right we have a result and this is
interesting the ipad air 4 scored 12 500
compared to 13 500 for the mini so that
is because the five core graphics in the
mini once again it is slowed down a
little bit compared to the iphone 13
pros in order to save battery life so it
actually uses less power
than the graphics chip inside the ipad
air so that means less heat less power
usage stuff like that but of course this
tests a lot of different things we have
particle physics we have hdr all that so
let's go ahead and test out the
performance when you're actually gaming
this is 3dmark's new wildlife extreme
i'm going to run the regular mode where
we can actually see what kind of
performance we're getting here and
taking a look at it the frame rates are
constantly higher on the new mini we
have 17 compared to 16 15 over here this
is reaching about 20. of course they're
actually a little bit off because the
mini loaded this a few seconds faster so
we'll do a ssd speed test here in just a
bit right over here we can see that the
mini is a little bit more choppy but
this is a 4k test that is pushing these
really really hard all right we have our
results here and it looks like the
difference is very similar slightly
higher than before we have 14.8 frames
per second compared to 16 so about 9 or
so
but once again other than a few frames
per second the difference is not that
big so now let's go ahead and close this
and let's test out the storage speed
because both of these come with 64 gigs
of storage they don't come with 128 you
have to spend another 150 if you want
the 256 gigabyte storage upgrade option
i have a jazz disk bench opened up right
here we're going to go ahead and hit
start on both of them i ran this a few
times just to make sure we're getting
consistent results because the results
are very interesting
over here with the ipad air we have a
911 megabyte per second read compared to
484 that's almost twice as fast for the
ipad air and then as far as right the
difference isn't as big the ipad air is
faster by about 30 megabytes per second
or so so looks like the storage the
memory that's built into the ipad is of
a higher class or faster now that's
weird because that benchmark loaded up
quicker with the mini maybe just because
of the faster a15 processor and now
let's talk about the cameras
on the front we have a huge difference
the ipad air 4 has an older camera
system whereas the mini has that new
center stage camera where it could zoom
out it's an ultra wide shot and they can
crop in digitally so it's much better if
you're going to be using facetime and
other meetings like zoom or anything
else here is that ultrawide camera on
the mini and the quality of the built-in
microphones of course you can record as
wide as this or you could choose to crop
in to have it look more like a standard
ipad and this is the microphone and
video quality from the ipad air 4. so as
you can see if you're holding it with
your hand it is pretty zoomed in now you
guys let me know which one sounded
better in terms of microphones down in
the comments section below now because
the mini's camera is an ultra wide it
has to crop in digitally to give you a
standard photo so go ahead and let me
know does it look much worse because of
that digital crop compared to the airs
or is it pretty close now here's a
comparison photo using the ipad's 12
megapixel cameras on the back you guys
let me know which looks better and both
of these can record 4k 60 frames per
second with those rear cameras but only
the ipad mini has that flash you guys
let me know if that is at all important
to you and now for our verdict should
you buy the new ipad mini 6
or should you buy the ipad air 4
well it really depends personally for me
i like the ipad mini a lot more i like
the size it's like a size that's very
convenient for a lot of things if you're
surfing the web if you're doing email
and you want to keep it in the tablet
form and especially if you're playing
games this is so convenient it is the
perfect size now with that it is newer
um it just got updated it's gonna not
gonna be updated for a while has the a15
processor it does perform better when
you're gaming it has a center stage
camera so i would be totally fine buying
this knowing that it's gonna be current
for a long time and i can just take it
around with me everywhere because it's
so small you just slip it into a bag
that's why i like this now there are
reasons to buy the ipad air for as well
if you're going to be watching a lot of
movies it does get louder and you have
that large display with that if you're
going to be drawing with apple pencil i
would definitely go for the ipad air 4.
with that if you're somebody just wants
to take notes the ipad mini is great
there's enough space to write you could
do multiple pages stuff like that but
for drawer people that draw for artists
you do want a larger canvas and along
with that if you're looking for
something that is a laptop replacement
you can buy a magic keyboard for it as
well and then this could be kind of like
your main laptop that could do most of
the tasks of a laptop so for that reason
the ipad air 4 is a lot more flexible
but you got to spend more money and deal
with the larger size and weight and then
if you want to add on a keyboard like
this you're spending a lot more money so
that is what i would buy depending on
what your use case is you guys let me
know your thoughts if you guys have any
specific questions you guys can ask down
in the comment section below with that
you guys can press that subscribe button
to help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers we would greatly appreciate
it check out one of those videos right
over there this max and i'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
you